cher Patrick chaise mes chers collègues
membres de la commission spéciale nous
sommes aujourd'hui réunis pour vous
recevoir Monsieur le mien niche cher
Jean-Noël Barrault vous êtes délégué
chargé de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications je vous remercie
vraiment monsieur le ministre d'avoir pu
vous rendre disponible dans un pas temps
à partir assez court pour venir devant
les membres de notre commission spéciale
discuter du projet loi que vous portez
que vous allez porter d'ici quelques
semaines l'examen va venir assez
rapidement début juillet un texte
d'application de tous ces règlements des
sa des ma data govenansakt aussi
pardonnez-moi les envicismes qui ont
fait l'objet d'ailleurs d'un examen
attentif de notre commission des
affaires européennes monsieur le
ministre le Sénat a choisi de constituer
une commission spéciale sur ce texte qui
rassemble les membres de toutes les
commissions permanentes ou presque ce
qui est assez rare c'est dire la
transversalité du sujet et c'est dire
aussi que les sujets présents dans votre
texte remplissent un large espace qui
doit mobiliser toutes les compétences du
Sénat
ses compétences justement je crois que
vous avez déjà pu largement les mesurer
dans le domaine du numérique notre
assemblée il faut bien le dire et le
revendique a été active dans le cadre
des négociations sur les projets de
règlement sur les services et les
marchés numériques avec des résolutions
européennes adoptées à l'unanimité le
Sénat également apporté des
contributions décisives au débat sur la
protection de l'enfance avec le rapport
sur l'industrie pornographique de la
délégation au droit des femmes et une
nouvelle résolution européenne sur les
abus sexuels sur les enfants ou encore
la souveraineté économique avec le
rapport de juillet 2022 de la commission
des affaires économiques et on pourrait
citer encore bien des sujets qui ont été
traités par des collègues dans
différents
rapports c'est dire si notre assemblée
est heureuse de voir enfin un texte qui
va nous permettre de mieux réguler et
sécuriser le cyber espace une régulation
qu'elle appelle de tous ses vœux depuis
un certain nombre d'années pas seulement
pour des questions de souveraineté
nationale ou souveraineté européenne
mais aussi mais aussi et surtout pour
enfin
réglementer un espace qui est devenu il
faut bien lire à certains égards par
moments une véritable jungle avec tous
les phénomènes et les graves
dysfonctionnements qu'on observe
phénomène d'harcèlement sur les enfants
cyberpornographiques contrefaçon
propos haineux en ligne des informations
manipulation de la formation et puis
tout le secteur économique dont on va
parler bien sûr
tout à l'heure je crois pouvoir dire en
introduction que notre voix a été
entendue et que nous reconnaissons que
dans les règlements européens et dans le
projet de loi plusieurs éléments que
nous avions défendus
s'y retrouve évidemment nous aurions
aimé aller plus loin d'ailleurs ça va
faire l'objet peut-être d'un débat tout
à l'heure mais déjà c'est une
satisfaction nous aurons un vrai débat
de fond monsieur le ministre vous le
vous comprenez avec nous rapporteurs
aussi experts sur ce sujet mais
l'ensemble des collègues
tentant de trouver par là une vraie
cohérence de nos positions je vous
propose une organisation assez simple et
traditionnelle une prise de parole de
votre part pour une dizaine de minutes
nous sommes tous penchés sur le texte
nous le connaissons je crois pouvoir
dire déjà plutôt bien l'essentiel sera
la place au débat et et aux questions et
je voudrais la parole successivement aux
deux rapporteurs et bien sûr à
l'ensemble des membres de notre
commission voilà monsieur le ministre
vous avez immédiatement la parole
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs c'est un grand
honneur un grand plaisir également
d'être parmi vous aujourd'hui je vous
remercie beaucoup pour cette invitation
et notamment évidemment la présidente
Catherine Morin de saillie le rapporteur
Patrick chaise Harry Potter Loïc Hervé
dans ce jour anniversaire ce jour
d'anniversaire je avec vous lui
souhaiter
un très joyeux anniversaire
votre commission la commission spéciale
qui s'est constituée est une assemblée
d'experts dont les travaux ont
d'ailleurs fortement nourri ce projet de
loi que je vais vous exposer dans
quelques instants je pense
particulièrement aux travaux sur
l'industrie de la pornographie un
chantier transpartisan d'ampleur qui a
décliné les potentiels de régulation du
secteur et donc un grand nombre des
recommandations ont été reprises dans le
projet de loi et je remercie Alexandra
Borsch
Laurence Rossignol et Laurence Cohen
pour leurs travaux mais je veux
également saluer les rapports de
Florence blatrix compta et de la
présidence notamment sur les enjeux les
enjeux et ambition relatives aux
règlements DSA donc le Règlement sur les
services numériques et le Règlement sur
les marchés numériques mais également le
travail de
Sophie prima notamment sur les enjeux et
les propositions d'action visant à
accroître notre souveraineté
technologique notamment dans le marché
de l'hébergement en nuages le marché du
cloud
on pourrait citer également les les
travaux sur la cybersécurité de Rémy
Cardon et d'Anne Catherine Loisier sur
les sujets de concurrence de
souveraineté numérique de Catherine
Morin de saillie Patrick Chaze Loïc
Hervé Sylvie Robert et Pierre Ouzoulias
matière de lutte contre la haine en
ligne les travaux de d'Alexandra borchio
fontaine Marie Mercier Xavier yakovili
et Pierre-Jean vers Zellen
sur le contrôle parental travaux de
Sylviane Noël et sur l'intelligence
artificielle qui est un autre des sujets
qui n'est pas traité directement dans le
dans le texte
mais qui est un sujet d'actualité les
travaux de d'André gatelin Catherine
Morin de saillie si elle pelva et Elsa
Schalke
l'insécurité que nos concitoyens
rencontrent au quotidien sur Internet
sapent leur confiance dans le numérique
tous les Français sont concernés et plus
particulièrement les Français les plus
vulnérables donc concitoyens les plus
modestes les plus âgés les plus éloignés
du numérique qui sont les proies
privilégiés des cybercriminels nos
enfants qui subissent en ligne des
atteintes brutales à leur innocence nos
entreprises aussi que la loi du plus
fort place dans la dépendance des géants
du numérique et puis notre démocratie
qui est soumise aux coups de butoir
incessantes des professionnels de la
désinformation face à l'accumulation de
ces désordres qui viennent jusqu'à
questionner parfois aux yeux de nos
concitoyens la pertinence de la
transition numérique la France ces
dernières années à montrer la voie au
niveau national avec des textes qui ont
été pris ces dernières années pour
lutter contre la désinformation ou
protéger l'enfance en ligne
au niveau européen avec ces règlements
que la France a porté notamment
et puis au niveau international avec des
initiatives multi-partites comme l'appel
de Chrys Church ou le forum de Paris sur
la paix qui ont permis à défaut d'ériger
des règles contraignantes d'éveiller la
conscience mondiale sur un certain
nombre de ces questions avec ce projet
de loi la première ministre a souhaité
inscrire que la première ministre a
souhaité inscrire à l'ordre du jour
parlementaire avant l'été qui a vocation
être enrichie à renforcer au Parlement
l'objectif est d'apporter des réponses
concrètes aux inquiétudes aux
difficultés et aux souffrances parfois
que le numérique peut causer dans la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens ce projet
de loi il s'est formé à partir de trois
affluents vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Présidente d'abord
les règlements européens que la France a
porté l'année dernière
lorsqu'elle présidait l'Union européenne
pour mettre fin aux abus des géants du
numérique et qui nécessitent que nous
prenions des mesures d'adaptation afin
qu'ils puissent correctement s'appliquer
dans notre pays le Règlement sur les
services numériques DSA qui fait entrer
les grandes plateformes dans l'air de la
responsabilité en leur imposant des
obligations de modération des contenus
qui leur sont signalés
en leur en rejoignant à analyser
corriger le risque systémique qu'elles
font peser sur le bien-être la santé de
leurs utilisateurs ou sur la qualité du
débat public leur interdisant de
proposer de la publicité ciblée sur les
mineurs notamment
contraignant à faire auditer leurs
algorithmes et à ouvrir leurs données
aux chercheurs
je vais attirer votre attention sur le
fait que
certaines des dispositions prévues par
ce règlement en d'ores et déjà été mis
en oeuvre par les géants du numérique
mais ce que vient faire ce règlement qui
est un compromis atteint au niveau
européen qui est peut-être pas aller
aussi loin que ce que la France aurait
souhaité mais qui a la force de ce
compromis européen c'est de prévoir un
régime de sanctions extrêmement lourde
dans le cas de manquement par les
entreprises concernées à ces obligations
nouvelles si pour cent du chiffre
d'affaires des amendes pouvant aller
jusqu'à 6% du chiffre d'affaires mondial
et puis une exclusion de l'Union
européenne en cas de manquement répété
le Règlement sur les marchés numériques
ensuite le DMA
qui a pour objet de rétablir l'équité
commerciale dans l'économie numérique et
de favoriser ainsi l'émergence d'acteurs
français et européens en fixant 26
interdictions qui correspondent à des
pratiques commerciales des loyales je
cite quelques exemples
l'auto préférence la faculté en tout cas
la pratique qui consiste pour un éditeur
de moteur de recherche par exemple de
faire remonter plus haut dans les
résultats des contenus qui sont produits
par une entreprise avec laquelle cet
éditeur de moteur de recherche est lié
cette pratique est déloyale elle sera
désormais interdite autre exemple la
pratique qui consiste pour le vendeur
d'un téléphone d'un smartphone de
préinstaller le moteur de recherche le
navigateur l'assistant personnel
il y a là une pratique commerciale
déloyale puisque ça n'est ni plus ni
moins que de la vente liée et lorsque
vous êtes éditeur de moteur de recherche
et que vous vous entendez entrer sur ce
marché
vous n'avez aucune chance d'y parvenir
tant le marché est verrouillé
dernier exemple l'utilisation pour des
fins publicitaires par un éditeur de
réseau social de contenu ou de donner
collectées sur un autre service édité
par la même entreprise du numérique qui
a là aussi une forme de d'accapa
d'acaparent du marché et donc une
pratique commerciale des loyal la
nouveauté instaurée par le Règlement sur
les marchés numériques c'est
qu'auparavant ces pratiques déloyales
étaient constatées et sanctionnées à
posteriori mais bien souvent des années
plus tard par les autorités de la
concurrence et que désormais il y a 26
interdictions qui sont faites par le
règlement a priori sans attendre
l'instruction
éventuelle et les années qui peuvent
passer entre le moment où la plainte est
déposée et l'instruction est faite et
puis la deuxième le deuxième élément
notable c'est là aussi la lourdeur si
l'on peut dire ou la puissance des
sanctions puisque c'est 10% du chiffre
d'affaires la première fois et les 20 %
du chiffre d'affaires mondial en cas de
manquement répété première influence ce
sont donc ces deux règlements européens
le deuxième je le disais tout à l'heure
ce sont les travaux parlementaires
députés comme des sénateurs issus
d'ailleurs de toutes les sensibilités
politiques je citais tout à l'heure le
rapport
d'Annick billon d'Alexandra borchio
Fontain Florence Cohen Laurence
Rossignol surexposition des mineurs au
porno et je voudrais citer également le
rapport d'Amel gaker Franck Montaugé
Sophie prima sur la souveraineté
économique qui inclut un chapitre dédié
à la souveraineté numérique et qui a
inspiré les mesures qui concernent le
marché du cloud troisième affluent les
consultations qui ont été menées
notamment dans le cadre du Conseil
national de la refondation vous allez
donc face à vous un texte qui instaure
des protections nouvelles pour nos
concitoyens pour nos enfants
nos entreprises et collectivités et pour
la démocratie au chapitre des des
mesures visant à proxexer nos
concitoyens j'en citerai trois la
première c'est le filtre anti-arnac qui
servira de rempart contre les campagnes
de mails et de SMS frauduleux on a tous
reçu un sms du compte personnel de
formation ou de la sécurité sociale nous
invitant à suivre un lien malveillant
c'est ainsi que 18 millions de Français
ont été victimes de cybercriminalité
l'année dernière dont la moitié ont
perdu de l'argent et ce sont je disais
les Français les plus fragiles les plus
démunis les plus éloignés du numérique
qui se retrouvent spolié de leurs
économies ou entraîner dans la spirale
infernale de l'usurpation d'identité
dont ils mettent parfois une décennie à
pouvoir se sortir il faut donc couper le
mal à la racine et dévitaliser le
commerce de ces mafia qui se sont
professionnalisés et qui ont fait de nos
smartphones et de nos tablettes l'INS
trument de la raquette deuxième mesure
une peine complémentaire de bannissement
des réseaux sociaux pendant 6 mois pour
les personnes reconnues coupables par le
juge de cyber-harcèlement cybercement
comme vous le savez est un phénomène qui
se développe massivement et touche
toutes les catégories d'âge qui touchent
plus particulièrement les femmes qui
sont 27 fois plus exposées aussi par
harcèlement que les hommes une violence
d'ailleurs dont nous consultations a
montré qu'elle se délocalise dans
l'espace physique puisque le
cybarcellement peut se muter en
harcèlement physique
alors qu'il a commencé sur les réseaux
sociaux les responsables c'est une
minorité d'internautes qui se comporte
en chef de meute et propagent la haine
et la violence comme des incendies sur
les réseaux sociaux en désignant à leur
communauté des victimes sur lesquelles
il déclenchent des raids de haine et de
violence cette mesure
frappera donc ses chefs de meute là où
ça fait mal en les privant de leur
caisse de résonance en confisquant leur
notoriété à l'image de l'interdiction de
des stades elle préviendra la récidive
et c'est donc peine complémentaire à une
condamnation pour cyber assez bon pour
une durée de 6 mois portée à un an
en cas de récidive et puis troisième
mesure de protection de nos concitoyens
l'encadrement des nouveaux types de jeux
en ligne
l'objectif est de définir un régime
pionnier et protecteur des utilisateurs
pour l'encadrement des jeux numériques
fondés sur les technologies émergentes
du web 3 c'est-à-dire des registres
distribués blockchain qui offre les
garanties nécessaires de protection des
mineurs de lutte contre le blanchiment
de lutte contre le financement du
terrorisme tout en permettant le
développement en France de ce type
d'activité au deuxième chapitre qui est
celui de la protection de nos enfants
deux mesures d'abord le blocage le
déréférencements et des amendes
dissuasives prononcées par l'arcom à
l'encontre des sites pornographiques qui
ne vérifieront pas l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs vous avez dû voir comme moi
la
publication de l'arcom il y a quelques
jours qui confirme qu'il y a bien dans
notre pays chaque mois 2 millions
d'enfants qui sont exposés à des
contenus pornographiques et qu'à 12 ans
la moitié des garçons dans notre pays
sont exposés chaque mois à ses contenus
dont nous voulons pourtant les préserver
tant les conséquences de cette
exposition sont sur leur santé sont
majeures troubles du sommeil troubles de
la tension troubles de l'alimentation
développement de conduite à risque hyper
sexualisation précoce notamment mais la
liste est plus longue que cela
malheureusement pourquoi cette situation
parce que les sites pornographiques ne
vérifient pas l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs malgré l'obligation qui
leur est faite par la loi du 30 juillet
du 20 juillet du 30 juillet 2020 il faut
donc soustraire nos enfants au
déferlement d'images
pornographique en accès libre sur
Internet déversé par il faut le dire des
mercenaires cupides et irresponsables
qui considère que le trafic que les
recettes publicitaires valent mieux que
la santé de nos enfants il y a une
procédure en cours
le tribunal judiciaire de Paris rendra
son verdict dans le cas de 5 sites
pornographiques le 7 juillet pour
l'avenir les mesures prévues par le
projet de loi nous permettront d'agir
plus vite et plus fort puis deuxième
mesure de protection de nos enfants une
peine d'un an d'emprisonnement et 250000
euros d'amende pour les hébergeurs qui
ne retireront pas les contenus
pédopornographiques qui leur sont
signalés par la police ou la gendarmerie
en moins de 24 heures
sur le modèle de la sanction qui
s'applique au non retrait des contenus
terroristes il y a une obligation
aujourd'hui qui est faite dans le droit
mais elle n'est pas sanctionnée par des
peines
alors même que c'est un phénomène quand
même assez massif puisque vos auditions
passées et à venir vous confirmeront
qu'il y a eu l'année dernière 74000
demandes de retraite contenu
pédopornographiques adressé aux
hébergeurs ce qui est absolument
considérable troisième chapitre la
protection de nos entreprises est
collectivités pour les entreprises
l'interdiction des frais de transfert
l'encadrement des avoirs commerciaux et
l'interopérabilité sur le marché de
l'informatique en nuage ou de
l'hébergement en nuages c'est à dire ce
marché du cloud ça a marché qui est très
concret entre les mains d'une poignée
d'acteurs d'entreprises qui abusent de
leur position dominante ce livre à des
pratiques commerciales déloyales et
place nos entreprises donc dans une
situation d'assujettissement il faut en
finir avec la loi du plus fort il faut
libérer nos entreprises de ce de ce jour
c'est une question de souveraineté qui
est une priorité de l'action que nous
menons avec Bruno Le Maire mais qui est
je le crois une priorité du Sénat
également au regard des rapports qui ont
été
remis à ce sujet je faisais référence à
un certain nombre d'entre eux dans mon
introduction
inspiré par ces travaux par les travaux
parlementaires cette mesure permettra
aux entreprises françaises de changer
beaucoup plus facilement de fournisseurs
de Cloud et donc de retrouver une forme
de liberté en faisant jouer la
concurrence et puis une mesure pour nos
collectivités avec la création d'une
base de données unique pour recenser
l'activité des meublés de tourisme qu'on
a vu apparaître dans l'actualité ces
dernières semaines c'est une mesure qui
en réalité pérennise une expérimentation
initiée par la loi Elan qui a associé
cinq collectivités et 5 plateformes de
location et qui a vocation à permettre
aux collectivités de pouvoir mesurer de
manière beaucoup plus simple la durée de
location des meublés de tourisme sur
leur territoire et donc de faire
appliquer la limite des 120nités par an
j'en finis avec la mesure de protection
de la démocratie avec la capacité donnée
à l'arcom de mettre en demeure et
d'ordonner le blocage des sites internet
diffusant des médias frappés par les
sanctions internationales comme celle
que l'Union européenne a prise contre RT
France et spout
la désinformation sur Internet est l'une
des menaces les plus lourdes qui pèsent
sur la démocratie on l'a vu avec la
sauce sur le Capitole aux États-Unis on
l'a vu avec la montée des mouvements
anti-vax qui aurait pu aggraver la
situation
sanitaire c'est une mesure qui
complétera notre arsenal pourrait lutter
efficacement et rapidement contre la
propagande des ennemis de la démocratie
même si en matière de lutte contre la
désarme en formation il faut toujours
agir avec la main tremblante et dans le
respect de la liberté d'expression et
c'est peut-être sur cela que je voudrais
terminer en vous redisant mesdames et
messieurs et sénateurs que ce texte qui
est qui emprunte à des travaux qui ont
été les vôtres et qui a vocation à être
enrichie par les travaux de cette
commission spéciale et travaux en séance
nous conduire à soutenir des
propositions qui qui pourront naître de
ces travaux là avec évidemment de ligne
rouge la première c'est d'éviter dans
ces la première de ces lignes rouges
c'est le respect des compromis trouvé au
niveau européen non pas que nous soyons
des fanatiques du compromis européen
mais que c'est grâce à ces compromis que
nous avons que nous allons obtenir
collectivement des concessions très
significatives de la part des géants du
numérique
la contrepartie de ces compromis c'est
que lorsque au niveau des États membres
des dispositions sont adoptées qui
empiète sur le champ de ces compromis
européens alors ces dispositions
deviennent fragiles car elles peuvent
être contestées devant les juridictions
européennes qui de manière constante ont
donné raison au plaignants contre les
États membres qui voulaient justifier
une exception
aux vertus et c'est bien légitime d'une
aspiration nationale singulière la
deuxième de ces lignes rouges c'est
qu'évidemment face aux drames que vivent
certains de nos concitoyens on pourrait
être tentés parfois d'aller très loin
dans les protections que nous voulons
créer dans l'espace numérique mais il
nous faut
également être vigilant à ne pas
empiéter trop trop loin sur les libertés
fondamentales qui sont les socles qui
constituent le socle de notre démocratie
mais connaissant la sagesse du Sénat et
son attachement aux libertés
fondamentales je suis convaincu que vous
saurez amélioré par vos travaux le
projet de loi qui vous est soumis je
vous remercie beaucoup madame la
Présidente
merci Monsieur le Ministre soyez assurés
au Sénat
on tente toujours de trouver le juste
équilibre avec nous sommes attachés
aussi
à une rigueur mais aux libertés
fondamentale et on a bien conscience des
limites de l'exercice de règlement
européen d'application directe mais nous
souhaitons malgré tout travailler le
mieux possible à l'amélioration de
celui-ci alors je vais donner de la
parole pour commencer à Patrick chess
sur le volet plus économique des sujets
que vous avez évoqués et puis on s'y
sera le café
merci ma présidente monsieur le ministre
alors j'ai une grande série de questions
je vais essayer de les réduire pour que
ne pas prendre le temps tout le temps de
cette commission je vais d'abord réagir
à vos propos monsieur le ministre
puisque finalement vous nous dites que
on est donc dans un jeu d'équilibre
entre
la stricte adaptation du droit national
au règlement européen et en même temps
si je me permets donc une communication
gouvernementale qui se concentre sur
dispositif nouveau
donc est-ce que pourrait nous préciser
vraiment le périmètre que vous souhaitez
donner à ce projet de loi ou égard à ces
deux contraintes
je vais me permettre de poser une série
de questions sur le filtre national de
cybersécurité grand public et puis je
changeais ensuite sur les autres thèmes
après vos réponses peut-être monsieur le
ministre pour plus de clarté
donc sur le filtre national de
cybersécurité les dispositifs déjà
existants de filtrage et de retrait des
contenus licite sont-ils suffisamment
efficaces
déjà une partie de la réponse mais
qu'est-ce qui justifie la mise en place
d'un nouveau dispositif de filtrage des
contenus pour les actes quotidiens de
cybervalveillance deuxième question
c'est pourquoi avoir prévu un dispositif
de filtrage des contenus ordonné par
voie administrative plutôt que par voie
judiciaire
troisième question le champ des infras
des infractions visées par ce dispositif
vous semble-t-il adapté et suffisant
des infractions supplémentaires
correspondant à d'autres actes
quotidiens si bienveillance devrait-elle
être ajoutée
quatrième question oui quatrième
question qui sera l'autorité
administrative désignée pour constater
les infractions les notifié la mise en
oeuvre des mesures conservatoires
est-ce que plusieurs autorités
administratives seront concernées et si
oui lesquels et enfin que pensez-vous de
la désignation de la CNIL comme garante
du caractère proportionné et justifié
des mesures prises par l'autorité
administrative première série de
questions monsieur le ministre
concernant notamment le filtre national
de cybersécurité grand public merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente sur le
périmètre du du texte des mesures
d'adaptation du droit national devait
être prise pour que les règlements sur
les marchés numériques sur les services
numériques et sur la gouvernance des
données puisse être appliquées je crois
qu'il
faut pas sous-estimer l'importance de
ces règlements qui a fait l'objet de
travaux sur lesquels la France côté
moteur et qui permettent de changer la
donne à condition qu'il soit mise en
oeuvre et nous avons des échanges
réguliers avec la Commission européenne
qui va être en première ligne pour les
faire appliquer
car le poids du marché unique le poids
du marché européen et le seul
susceptible de faire vraiment plier et
évoluer les pratiques des géants du
numérique c'est c'est cela le mérite de
ces règlements de faire levier des
du marché unique pour obtenir des
concessions significatives de la part de
ces acteurs ou en tout cas une
conformité avec les valeurs qui sont les
nôtres
si nous régulions en ordre dispersé dans
l'Union européenne
les géants du numérique se joueraient de
nos régulations nationales les mettrai
en concurrence vous auriez des de
l'arbitrage et du dumping et nous ne
parviendrons n'ayons pas à faire
fondamentalement changer un certain
nombre de pratiques que ce soit en
matière de responsabilité sur les
réseaux sociaux et en matière d'équité
commerciale
ensuite
s'agissant de la deuxième question qui
est sur l'efficacité
des dispositifs existants de filtrage et
de
retrait des contenus existants ils ont
proulé leur efficacité et d'ailleurs
le la représentation nationale se penche
régulièrement sur sur ces dispositifs
qu'ils opèrent par voie administrative
ou ou par voie judiciaire et qui visent
tous à protéger les internautes contre
différentes catégories de contenu ou de
sites que ce soit des contenus haineux
atteintes aux personnes atteintes aux
droits d'auteur apologie du terrorisme
lutte contre les fausses les
informations périodes électorales etc
cependant les aucun des dispositifs
existants ne permet de couvrir le
périmètre et l'objet de ce filtre anti
arnaque ce filtre national de
cybersécurité à savoir les sites
intrinsèquement et ontologiquement
cyber malveillant qui sont créés par les
cybercriminels pour leur permettre de
conduire des opérations de hameçonnage
c'est à dire de pillage des données
personnelles ou d'injection de logiciels
malveillants dans les terminaux pour
détourner des moyens de paiement c'est
donc cela l'objectif qui différencie le
filtre anti-arnac des dispositifs de
filtrage existants
pourquoi avoir prévu c'était la
troisième question un dispositif de
filtrage par voie administrative plus
plutôt que par voie judiciaire nous y
avons réfléchi et en nous basant sur une
analyse précise et éclairer des
phénomènes que nous souhaitions endiguer
ainsi que sur des comparaisons
internationales nous avons retenu cette
approche administrative la réalité de ce
phénomène c'est qu'aujourd'hui une
campagne de finie de phishing de
hameçonnage s’orchestre en quelques
clics et touche des centaines de
milliers de nos concitoyens en quelques
jours je vous invite d'ailleurs si si
vous en avez reçu il y a par exemple
quelques semaines à cliquer une nouvelle
fois sur les liens qui qui de ces faux
SMS pour qui qui vous inviter à vous
diriger vers ces sites malveillants bien
souvent quelques jours
quelques jours après la réception du
message le site est d'ores et déjà
désactivé puisque une fois qu'on a
touché suffisamment de de compte une
fois qu'on a obtenu suffisamment de
données personnelles et bien on fait
disparaître le site il faut donc dans ce
domaine là agir très rapidement d'où la
voie administrative tout en entourant le
dispositif et bien de toutes les
garanties les toutes les précautions
nécessaires c'est c'est ainsi que nous
avons procédé à la rédaction de cette
article sur le champ des instructions
visées par le le dispositif notre
objectif a été double dans la rédaction
de l'article nous inscrire dans les
canons de la juryse prudence
constitutionnelle en prévoyant un champ
d'application précis pour minimiser le
risque d'atteinte au Liberté protégées
par la Constitution puisqu’après tout on
va rediriger automatiquement des
internautes vers une page sécurisée et
puis nous conformer de façon la plus
stricte à l'esprit de la mesure il
s'agit d'un outil de protection cyber et
qui doit donc être limité à la lutte
contre la cybercriminalité c'est le sens
des infractions que nous avons retenu et
qui ont qui sont généralement mobilisés
par le juge lorsqu'il est saisi dans une
affaire de hameçonnage de phishing quant
à savoir s'il faut en ajouter d'autres
nous sommes ouverts à la réflexion à
condition que cela ne dénature pas le
dispositif qui n'a pas vocation à
filtrer de façon indiscriminée tous les
contenus à problèmes sur internet mais
bien sûr qui vise à piller les
internautes de leur donner personnel ou
bancaires et sa gestion de l'autorité
administrative désignée par désigné pour
constater les les infractions le champ
d'application du dispositif porte sur
des objets qui sont parfois à cheval
entre les compétences de différentes
autorités administratives des autres dès
lors plusieurs de ces autorités seront
sollicité je pense
à des autorités mais pas seulement à
Annecy au GIP asima à la DGCCRF ou comme
cybergen
ou l'OCL CTIC ainsi qu'un certain nombre
d'autorité administratives indépendantes
tels que l'AMF la CPR et la NJ qui
chacune reçoivent de temps en temps et
parfois plus que de plus souvent que de
temps en temps des notifications de
sites identifié comme étant malveillants
l'idée c'est donc bien de mutualiser en
quelque sorte les l'information reçue en
temps réel par l'ensemble de ces
organisations et de pouvoir ensuite au
travers du dispositif du filtre
anti-arnac la diffuser le plus
rapidement possible au fournisseur
d'accès Internet pour qu'ils puissent
mettre en oeuvre le filtre et éviter ce
type de cyber arnaque
par ailleurs
sur les sujets de la CNIL
associé à ce filtre anti arnaque semble
être une bonne chose que et un gage de
confiance que d'avoir un régulateur au
fait des enjeux de liberté sur Internet
et soucieux de la protection de la vie
privée des utilisateurs bien que le
filtre n'est pas vocation à faire
intervenir de traitement de données
personnelles nous n'avons pas décidé une
année unilatéralement de confier cette
responsabilité une personnalité
qualifiée rattachée à la CNIL nous
l'avons fait dans le cadre d'un dialogue
avec la CNIL elle-même et pris en compte
aussi bien ses observations sur le
dispositif que son souhait dans
contrôler l'application ce que j'imagine
que la CNIL pourra vous confirmer lors
des auditions ou de l'audition que vous
ferez-elle
merci Monsieur le Ministre c'était le
premier chapitre deuxième chapitre sur
la régulation du marché informatique en
nuage vous avez
duré qu'une sommes attaché à la
Francophonie donc nous parlons de
l'informatiquement on y va
la présidente alors sur ce sujet est-ce
qu'il y en a un cadrement des crédits
d'informatique en nuage et prévu à
l'échelle européenne ou est-ce que il
s'agit d'une initiative française
autrement dit est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un
risque de pénaliser injustement les
opérateurs français et en leur activité
donc sur notre territoire si nous sommes
les seuls à anticiper l'application du
Data Act ou à adopter des dispositions
plus restrictives
deuxième question sur l'encadrement des
crédits cloud ou nuage
pourquoi la durée maximale de validité
et leurs conditions de renouvellement ne
sont pas fixées dans la loi quelle durée
et quelles conditions de renouvellement
recommanderiez vous
question suivante sur les frais sortant
de donner pourquoi maintenir les frais
de migration facturés lorsqu'une
entreprise change définitivement de
fournisseurs de
Cloud alors que les autres frais sont
supprimés comment est-ce que cette
dispositions s'articulent avec le Data
Act qui prévoit une période de trois ans
pour la suppression de ses frais
question suivante concrètement qu'est-ce
que l'interopérabilité des services du
cloud pourquoi est-ce que ce n'est pas
précisé est défini dans la loi
autre question
en parallèle qu'est-ce que la
portabilité des services du cloud
pourquoi est-ce que cela n'est pas
précisé et défini dans la loi et enfin
que pensez-vous du rôle attribué à la
recette du renforcement de ses pouvoirs
de sanction d'enquête et de règlement
des litiges est-ce suffisant nous sommes
un peu sceptiques quant à la capacité de
la recette assurer cette régulation
supplémentaire
voilà Monsieur le Ministre sont des
questions auxquelles nous sommes
extrêmement attentifs au rapport de
l'imprima et de ses collègues de ma
collègue aussi avec Blanche Patrice
content d'anticipation du Data Act donc
merci de vous répondre nous allons y
être très vigilant
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur sur la question de
l'encadrement des crédits d'informatique
en nuage
la réponse est non ce n'est pas une
disposition qui est prévue à ce stade
dans le règlement pour les sur les
données qui est en cours de discussion
au niveau européen avec des des
trilogues entre la Commission européenne
le le Parlement et le Conseil
les
le l'interdiction des frais de transfert
l'interopérabilité figure e dans le
Règlement sur les données
il est d'ailleurs prévu dans le texte
des clauses d'extinction qui font que
lorsque le Règlement sur les données
s'appliquera de plein droit alors les
dispositions prévues dans ce projet de
loi c'est un don de plein droit
en revanche sur les avoir informatique
de les crédits d'informatique en nuage
nous les avons introduit dans le texte
en suivant pour cela les recommandations
des rapports que vous venez de citer
jugeant que
cette proposition nous semblait
pertinente puisque je le rappelle
l'objectif ici est de desserrer un
marché qui ou en tout cas de
déverrouiller un marché sur lequel
quelques acteurs se sont octroyés une
position de monopole en offrant des
avoir commerciaux qui s'apparentent à
l'entrée à une forme de dumping
qui empêche l'entrée de la concurrence
ou en tout cas de lampe qui râle qui qui
compromet la capacité des nouveaux
entrants à entrer sur ce marché
et puis ensuite à la sortie en facturant
des frais de transfert parfois
démesurées donc à l'entrée comme à la
sortie des pratiques déloyales
pratiquées par les les acteurs dominants
élimine toute forme de concurrence et
place donc les entreprises françaises
les entreprises utilisatrices dans une
situation de grande dépense
le Règlement sur les données comme je le
disais tout à l'heure les compromis
européens ne sont pas toujours
totalement satisfaisant mais ils ont le
mérite d'être européen et donc de faire
levier du marché unique donc dans le
Règlement sur les données le les avoir
les avoir ou les crédits informatiques
en nuage ne figurent pas mais il nous
semble qu'il y a là et nous l'avons
vérifié une mesure qui peut être prise
au niveau national sans compromettre ou
sans rentrer dans le champ du Règlement
sur les sur les données et ces raisons
pour laquelle elle figure dans le texte
ensuite se pose la question de de la
durée de validité de ces avoir
d'informatique en nuage puisque
nous avions deux possibilités lorsque
nous avons décidé de cet encadrement le
premier aurait été de supprimer ou de
plafonner c'est
ces crédits c'est avoir commerciaux
nous avons écarté cette possibilité en
raison du fait que beaucoup des
entreprises d'utilisatrices de ces
crédits commerciaux
sont des jeunes entreprises innovantes
pour lesquelles ces crédits commerciaux
s'apparentent ou peuvent s'apparenter à
une forme de financement
nous avons retenu une autre approche qui
consiste à un encadrement dans le temps
qui permet plutôt que de jouer au plus
tôt que de brider des montants éventuels
qu'une jeune entreprise innovante
pourrait solliciter pour co-financer son
développement et bien en tout cas de
faire apparaître ces crédits commerciaux
pour ce qu'ils sont c'est-à-dire une
forme d'échantillonnage plutôt que une
sorte de dumping déguisée
éliminant des facto la concurrence
se pose la question de la durée de
validité
qui dans le texte est renvoyé au décret
je crois qu'il est nécessaire que nous
puissions viser l'objectif de de faire
en sorte que ces avoir commerciaux
restent une forme d'échantillons c'est à
dire je prends l'avoir commerciale pour
tester la solution d'un tel ou d'un tel
et non pas pour rester avec lui pendant
des années jusqu'au moment où je suis
enfermé dans la solution de d'un acteur
dominant il nous paraît donc une durée
de validité est relativement courte de 3
à 6 mois serait un point de départ
intéressant mais
cela suppose sans doute d'avoir quelques
discussions
complémentaires et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous allons proposer que que
cela puisse passer par voie
réglementaire
pourquoi maintenir les frais de
migration alors que le texte propose la
suppression des des frais de transfert
si le manque de transparence est
prévisibilité des frais de migration
contribuent à la dynamique d'enfermement
propriétaire sur le marché ceci peuvent
correspondre à des coûts légitimes et
incompressifs pour les fournisseurs de
services particulier les frais de
migration varient de manière
significative en fonction de la
complexité du projet de migration
concerné la migration des données RH
d'une PME mobilisera moindre ressources
que la migration du système
d'information d'une grande entreprise
bancaire ainsi il peut y avoir des frais
qui se justifient lorsque l'on fait la
migration à ce titre les autorités
françaises ont défendu dans le cadre des
négociations du Règlement sur les
données un encadrement basé sur les
coûts réels supportés par le fournisseur
de services dans le cadre du processus
de migration fin d'éviter de faire peser
un poids 10 proportionné sur les
fournisseurs de services français
européen qui seraient davantage impactés
en raison de la difficulté à amortir ses
coûts via leur base de clients moins
large
l'interdiction de la facturation de
frais au titre du transfert de données
s'inscrit en pleine cohérence avec
l'esprit de ce qui a été défendu au
niveau européen c'est une approche par
les par les coûts et puis une période
transitoire durant laquelle les
fournisseurs ne pourront facturer des
frais dépassant les coûts réels
supportés au titre des transferts de
données et on regarde la baisse
constante du prix de la bande passante
principale coût liée au transfert de
données et des importantes divergences
entre les pratiques des fournisseurs de
services alternatifs et dominants la
suppression des frais de transfert de
données apparaître la meilleure
approximation du coût réel supporté par
les fournisseurs de services c'est ce
qui nous a conduit à prendre cette
option dans le texte
pourquoi
portabilité et
interopérabilité ne sont pas définis en
tant que tel dans le dans le texte et
bien en réalité parce que
l'interopérabilité
repose sur la compatibilité des formats
de données et sur l'accès à des
interfaces permettant aux différents
services de dialoguer et d'échanger des
données d'un instant des interfaces de
programmation applicative les API
et c'est principe d'interopérativité de
portabilité ne peuvent trouver une
définition satisfaisante qu'au travers
de l'édiction de spécifications
techniques
quel doit être la nature de ses API
quelles sont les caractèresistiques qui
qui doivent
figurer ou qui doivent être pouvoir être
mobilisés les les dispositions
introduites dans le projet de loi
directement inspiré du projet de
règlement européen sur les données pour
suivre l'objectif de définir en lien
étroit avec les utilisateurs et
fournisseurs de services les éléments
techniques qui devront faire l'objet
d'un travail de définition collectif
afin de rendre effective
l'interopérabilité la portabilité entre
les services Cloud et c'est donc lacep
dont il est prévu que le texte fasse le
le régulateur si l'on peut dire de cette
interopérabilité de cette portabilité
alors vous m'interrogez monsieur le
rapporteur sur le rôle attribué à
l'ARCEP
je pourrais je voudrais prendre en
disant que l'évolution constante du
paysage numérique et de l'économie de la
donnée
et bien créer un contexte dans lequel la
proposition d'étendre le mandat de
l'Arcelle pour rien inclure la
régulation des services d'informatique
en nuages est un choix logique
stratégique la recette ayant démontré
une expertise notable dans le domaine de
la régulation numérique de la
normalisation technique et de
l'interopérabilité et donc bien
positionné pour assumer ces nouvelles
responsabilités son expérience solide
dans la gestion des sujets en jeu
économiques dans le secteur des
télécommunications renforce cette
proposition cette approche est alignée
avec les objectifs du Règlement sur les
données du Règlement sur les gouvernance
des données et convergent avec la vision
de la Commission européenne et de nos
partenaires européens alors évidemment
pour permettre à la recette de répondre
effectivement à ces nouvelles exigences
une augmentation de personnel est
actuellement à l'étude dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finance
merci Monsieur le Ministre juste avant
de passer au sujet suivant avec notre
rapporteur je me tourne chose dans mes
collègues parce que c'est un point
important que cette informatique en
nuage est-il des questions
complémentaires à poser au ministre sur
le sujet madame blatisfonta
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre
en effet cette dimension du texte nous
semble important nous y avons longuement
travaillé dans le cadre notre rapport
sur le DSA et c'est vraiment un marché
stratégique
qui
conditionne la souveraineté
la souveraineté numérique elle a
compétitivité économique et donc on sait
rendu compte au cours de nos de nos
auditions que ce et vous l'avez dit ce
marché est très largement dominé par des
opérateurs extra-européens et même si
les opérateurs européens ont progressé
en chiffre d'affaires dans ce domaine du
cloud ils ont régressé en termes de part
on nous sommes passés de 27 à 13% de la
part de ce marché une baisse donc de
14 points en 5 ans donc il faut vraiment
mettre un frein à cette hémorragie pour
nos entreprises
donc on se rend compte aussi que les que
globalement les PME les ETI sont
encore peu sur ce marché donc il y a
vraiment vraiment un enjeu là à
permettre à nos à nos entreprises
européennes d'être sur ce marché donc
j'avais des questions similaires à
celles de mon collègue Patrick chese
donc je ne vais pas je ne vais pas les
poser à nouveau mais peut-être que sur
la question justement des PME et TPE
est-ce que les frais de migration est-ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas envisager de ne
pas facturer des frais de migration au
TP au TPE et au PME dans la mesure où
c'est vraiment un enjeu de permettre à
ces entreprises de
[Musique]
d'avancer sur le sur le marché du clone
du cloud donc c'est une option que vous
n'avez que vous avez écarté
pouvez-vous nous dire pourquoi donc
voilà c'était ma principale question sur
ce sujet je me permets juste de la
compléter en
vous posant une question qui est une
réflexion assez forte qui est de dire
que les grandes plateformes pour capter
en fait des marchés font des offres
gratuites est-ce que finalement on
devrait autoriser les autres gratuites
qui correspondent à une forme de dumping
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice
je
j'entends votre remarque je crois que
l'objectif est le principal qui est
poursuivi par par ces articles c'est
c'est de permettre de déverrouiller un
marché qui aujourd'hui
concerne plutôt vous l'avez dit les
grandes entreprises que les plus petites
ou moyennes qui n'ont pas encore fait
leur migration vers vers le Cloud
je je
vous propose d'examiner cette idée que
vous soulevez
et notamment pour avoir un ordre de
grandeur de ce que sont les frais de
migration sur ce sur les PME qui qui
sont en cours de migration vers vers le
Cloud mais qui ne l'ont pas encore tout
à fait faites et de vous revenir avec un
avis un peu plus un peu plus définitif
sur la la l'opportunité de différencier
le régime qui s'appliquerait aux
migration à la migration selon qu'on est
en dessous
du seuil de PM et à la question de
madame la Présidente les offres
gratuites
me semblent ça parenter à des avoir
commerciaux et il me semble donc tomber
sous le sous le coup de l'interdiction
qui est prévu dans le texte là aussi je
vous propose de faire une vérification
avant de vous apporter une réponse
définitive
une dernière question avant de repasser
la parole à Patrick chaise qui est
importante qui est le déverrouillage
nécessaire techniquement financièrement
juridiquement de ce marché amené à être
en fort développement ce marché du nuage
informatique pour la bonne et sa
pression nous avons besoin de solutions
souveraine pour nous donner sensibles et
critiques monsieur le ministre vous le
savez pourrait-on pas envisager à
travers ce texte d'afficher d'une
manière ou d'une autre ce qu'est une
donnée sensible ce qu'est une donnée
critique pour notre sécurité nationale
et des facto s'appuyer sur les
propositions que nous avions faites se
dire que il faut que ces données en fait
elles soient dans un Cloud souverain
sommes très préoccupés je tiens à dire
au nom de tous mes collègues parle de
devenir nos données santé nous avons
maintes fois interrogé le ministre de la
santé mais vous-même et votre
prédécesseur sur le devenir de la
plateforme des noyées de santé voilà
autrement appelé mais c'est terminé
cette appellation Microsoft
[Musique]
première élément
et il annonçait
ce jour là que la la définition des
données sensibles serait prochainement
présenté dans le cadre de
l'actualisation de la circulaire de
Cloud de centre à son 9e paragraphe puis
il évoqué une deuxième un deuxième
élément qui était que qui était en
réalité un encouragement fait aux
entreprises en particulier celle qui qui
se situe dans des secteurs critiques
celles qui sont des osse ou des Oliv de
considérer très sérieusement
l'opportunité de faire la même chose que
les administrations sans quoi à terme
des mesures de coercition pourrait être
prise
ce que je puis vous dire c'est que
depuis lors
nous avons fait deux choses la première
c'est que nous discutons nous avec nos
nos amis européens pour faire en sorte
que le schéma de certification du cloud
en cours de discussion au niveau
européen en vertu de du Règlement sur la
cybersécurité qui prévoit que ces
schémas de certification qui sont
volontaires peuvent être créés dans un
certain nombre de secteurs et que
lorsqu'ils sont créés les États membres
peuvent s'y référer
d'une manière d'une manière volontaire
mais que lorsqu'ils aient lorsqu'ils
sont créés ils écrasent les schémas de
certification nationaux pourquoi est-ce
que nous consacrons autant d'énergie à
convaincre nos amis européens en tout
cas certains de nos amis américains qui
sont européens qui sautent un lapsus qui
sont réticents à
s'imposer comme nous le faisons
l'immunité à l'extraterritorialité des
législations extra-européennes et
américaines en particulier
bien parce que ce schéma de
certification cils dans son niveau de
sécurité le plus élevé intégré
et il intégrera ces mensuels plus cher
les mêmes critères que ceux que nous
avons retenu pour notre certification
nationale alors les acteurs français les
acteurs européens qui ont choisi de
faire certifier leur solution qui ont
investi du temps et des moyens pour le
faire pourronter l'or
passeporté si l'on peut expression leur
solution dans le reste de l'Union
européenne en revanche si cette
certification volontaire si ce schéma de
certification européen ne retenez pas
dans son niveau de sécurité le plus
élevé l'immunité au législation
extraterritoriales
notre certification c'est que new cloud
serait illégal il deviendrait illégal en
France
de de
d'imposer l'immunité à
l'extraterritorialité pour des
administrations pour des entreprises etc
sauf évidemment pour des peut-être des
motifs
explicites de sécurité nationale donc
nous menons cette discussion nous avons
des débats serrés avec un certain nombre
d'État membre notamment les Pays-Bas qui
qui derrière eux emmène je dirais le
groupe des pays qui sont les plus
réticents nous avons bon espoir mais
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous n'avions pas jusqu'à la semaine
dernière
publier cette circulaire actualisée elle
a été le 31 mai et dans son neuvième
paragraphe elle fait apparaître la
définition des données sensibles que les
administrations devront désormais
lorsqu'elles font leur migration vers
l'informatique en nuage placé dans de
Cloud certifié en parallèle
nous soutenons les acteurs et notamment
les acteurs français qui engagent le
processus de certification de l'ancien
pour de pour que leurs offres soient
certifiées secs
notamment grâce à un guichet que nous
avons ouvert il y a quelques mois on
s'était engagés le 12 septembre dernier
qui donne un petit coup de pouce
financier ou notamment aux petits et
moyennes entreprises de du cloud lorsque
elles veulent faire certifier une
solution mais que mais qu'elles n'ont
pas la taille suffisante pour absorber
les coûts fixes associés au processus de
certification
merci Monsieur le Ministre tout cela est
assez technique on l'aura compris
ce qui nous importe c'est que les
données sensibles des des Français et
des facto des Européens puissent être
bien protégés contre une législation
extraordinaire pour l'instant qui nous
est défavorable et que forcément
nos discussions vont se poursuivre sur
ce sujet nous y serons très très
attentifs alors je repasse la parole
tout de suite à Patrick chaise sur un
sujet très important aussi qui concerne
les jeux à objet numérique monétisable
pour lequel un nouveau cadre juridique
est en cours d'élaboration voilà chers
Patrick je te passe la parole merci ma
présidente monsieur ministre sur ce
sujet si vous deviez définir simplement
ce que sont les jeux objets numériques
monétisable quelle définition
retiendrait et vous
quel encadrement de ces nouvelles
pratiques de jeux en ligne
préconisez-vous compte tenu des risques
sociaux et sanitaires qui leur sont
associés et enfin sur cet article
comment justifier vous le recours à une
habilitation à légiférer par ordonnance
et le senda n'aime pas beaucoup voilà
habilité et le gouvernement a géré par
ordonnance
c'est pour ça que je le dis
par rapport
donc pour une vraie justification
comment définir ces jeux bien il s'agit
de jeux d'un nouveau genre qui se situe
à la confluence entre les jeux vidéo et
les jeux
d'argent et de hasard et qui s'appuie ou
qui sont nés de la technologie des
registres distribués la blockchain qui
permet d'isoler la propriété d'un actif
numérique ce qui veut dire que on peut
désormais détenir un actif numérique en
avoir la pleine propriété et donc en
quelque sorte jouer avec ou l'utiliser
comme un support de jeu je vous donne un
exemple le jeu stable
développé par le PMU et lancer il y a
quelques mois qui reposent sur une
plateforme numérique qui permet aux
utilisateurs d'acquérir des jetons
d'enfants jupe donc des jetons qui
prennent l'apparence de chevaux de
course
et qui sont reliés à un cheval dans le
monde physique et à ses performances
dans le monde réel et qui ainsi permet
de d'organiser des jeux d'un nouveau
type et
en s'appuyant sur ces technologies de de
blockchain enfin du web 3
et c'est donc précisément parce que se
trouve à la confluence de deux
de deux types de
de jeux existants les jeux vidéo et les
jeux d'argent et de hasard qu'ils nous
paraît important puisque nous avons un
écosystème Flores florissant du web 3
pas seulement sur les jeux mais dans
d'autres domaines également de créer un
cadre qui permet à la fois à
l'innovation de ce développer en France
et puis en Europe tout en créant le
niveau de protection suffisant pour les
utilisateurs et puis
garantissant la lutte effective contre
le blanchiment d'argent et le
financement du terrorisme
l'esprit dans lequel nous nous plaçons
et celui qui a présidé à la conception
en 2018 d'un régime qui s'appelle le
régime San
pour les crypto actifs dans le cadre de
la loi pacte ce régime a été construit
qui soulevait au départ quelques
interrogations mais qui a été conçu
précisément pour créer un cadre
suffisamment souple pour que
l'innovation puisse se développer pour
que la France soit d'ailleurs attractive
pour l'innovation
mais suffisamment protecteur pour créer
un niveau de confiance suffisamment
élevé
5 ans plus tard que s'est-il passé et
bien le cadre que nous avions défini a
permis d'attirer en France
les principaux leaders mondiaux dans ce
domaine et de susciter en France des
vocations entrepreneuriales très très
importante
la semaine dernière encore hier soir
encore nous avons reçu la confirmation
qu'un acteur américain
de ce domaine là avait choisi la France
pour installer c'est pour s'installer
pourquoi choisir la France alors qu'il
est évidemment aux États-Unis parce que
les États-Unis à l'époque ne
s'étendaient aucun cadre régulatoire
lorsque les scandales ont éclaté
l'automne dernier avec le scandale FTX
par exemple les Etats-Unis ont fait
marche machine arrière toute on serrait
les boulons d'une manière sans doute
excessive conduisant un certain nombre
d'acteurs américains non seulement
ouvrir des surcursales en Europe mais
parfois carrément à se délocaliser des
États-Unis vers l'Europe et je précise
que le cadre européen qui va s'appliquer
à partir de 2024 le cadre Mika est
directement inspiré du cadre français
qui avait donc fait ses preuves et nous
à peu près à l'abri de scandale tels que
ceux qu'on a vécu l'automne dernier
en partie à l'abri même si on n'est
jamais à la prix à l'abri d'une fraude
massive ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que au fond et j'en viens ensuite à la
question de l'habitation différente au
fond c'est la même chose que nous
essayons de construire pour ce type de
jeu là c'est à dire une réglementation à
la fois protectrice à la fois
susceptible de conduire un peu plus
d'innovation et si nous le faisons
suffisamment intelligemment à inspirer
la réglementation qui viendra au niveau
européen pour que les gens viennent
faire de la France leur camp de base
pour soit qu'il soit déjà en France soit
qu'il soit à l'étranger pour leur
expansion européenne autrement dire
venir innover innover en France quand on
veut s'adresser au marché européen alors
pourquoi le recours à une habitation à
légiférer par ordonnance
il est nécessaire pour pouvoir
coordonner dans des délais suffisants
des travaux interministériels
particulièrement techniques et complexe
qui mobilisent de nombreuses
administrations au sein de différentes
branches de l'exécutif
le ministère de l'Économie ministère
l'intérieur il sert de l'agriculture il
sert des sports ministère de la Culture
qui nécessitent également le concours de
plusieurs autorités de régulation la NJ
la CNIL track fin l'AMF à CPR harcom par
ailleurs il est nécessaire pour
permettre des consultations des
différents acteurs du secteur et des
secteurs voisins celui des jeux vidéo et
celui des jeux d'argent et de hasard il
n'en demeure pas moins monsieur le
rapporteur que l'objectif est d'avancer
le plus rapidement possible sur la
création de ces dispositions de manière
à pouvoir présenter au plus vite au
Parlement et de préférence au Sénat des
dispositions en dur
nous avons bien pris le point que vous
avez soulevé vous-même ainsi que madame
la Présidente et nous allons essayer de
faire en sorte qu'au plus vite ces
dispositions puissent vous puissent vous
être présenté vous doutez qu'on a été
saisi par l'ensemble des acteurs du
monde du jeu plus classique qui
craignent une distorsion en réalité de
concurrence à travers l'adaptation d'un
texte qui leur serait finalement
défavorable portant moins d'exigence au
secteur du jeu en ligne et que forcément
on sera attentive à ces sujets de
manière à ce que le texte proposé si
textes il y a vous y travaillez je sais
ça pas une quelque sorte un dégonflage
de l'architecture classique ce qui
serait terrible parce que on a besoin
aussi de régulation sérieuse sur
l'Internet où ce sont des jeux d'argent
vous l'avez sûr vous l'avez vous-même
souligné bien je demande en rapporteur
de terminer l'ensemble des questions qui
lui sont propres
alors des questions sur les meublés de
tourisme
notamment comment le dispositif de
centralisation des données relatives aux
meublés de tourisme permettra-t-il aux
communes de mieux contrôler la
conformité des locations sur leur
territoire
deuxième question selon l'étude d'impact
du projet de loi le taux de
non-conformité de l'offre de meublés de
tourisme pour atteindre 34% à Paris et
46% à Lyon comment expliquer vous
l'ampleur de ce taux de conformité
troisième question qui serait
l'organisme des uniques désigné pour
mettre en place la plateforme de
déclaration à destination des communes
et des plateformes numériques de la
location touristique et enfin
la proposition de règlement européen sur
les locations de courte durée est en
cours de négociation comment
anticipez-vous cette future régulation
au niveau européen et le dispositif
prévu par le présent projet de loi et
peut-être pour
finir les questions une question qui
concerne l'adaptation du droit de la
consommation comment se matérialisera la
lutte donc contre les Dark Partners ces
interfaces conçues de façon à tromper ou
manipuler les internautes consommateurs
une équipe spécifique des gscrf était
prévue à l'image de la brigade de
l'influence commerciale
ce ministre merci Madame présidente
monsieur le rapporteur comment le
dispositif de centralisation des données
relatives au meublée de tourisme
permettra-t-il aux communes de mieux
contrôler à conformité de le délocation
sur leur territoire aujourd'hui les
communes concernées
sont contraintes d'aller chercher à la
main si l'on peut dire les informations
liées à l'application de la limite des
120 jours applicable à la location des
résidences principales notamment grâce à
ce dispositif de centralisation des
échanges elles n'auront plus à formuler
qu'une seule demande plutôt qu'une
demande par plateforme afin de d'obtenir
ces informations et sera donc beaucoup
plus facile pour elle d'identifier les
manquements des loueurs à leur
obligation de déclaration et au respect
du seuil des 120 jours de location appli
par an applicable aux résidents
principales et par ailleurs ce guichet
unique ou cette base de données unique
permettra une harmonisation une
fiabilisation des données ainsi qu'une
automatisation des processus bref une
vraie simplification
pourquoi des taux de non-conformité
aussi élevés nos le taux de non
conformité réglementaire correspond au
pourcentage d'annonces publiées
présentent pas de numéro
d'enregistrement il est effectivement
vous l'avez dit relativement élevé dans
les marchés touristiques dans l'ensemble
des marchés touristiques d'ailleurs pour
lesquels des données sont mises à
disposition par inside Airbnb et
récupérer par des techniques de
moissonnage sur internet ici il faut
préciser quand même qu'il ne s'agit que
d'estimation qui sont réalisées à partir
de données partielles alors pourquoi des
taux si
faible et bien cela s'explique par un
facteur qui relève des loueurs eux-mêmes
excenter un certain nombre de
propriétaires ne respectent pas la
réglementation en vigueur en particulier
l'obtention d'un numéro d'enregistrement
ou la déclaration de changement d'usage
ou encore la limitation des 120 jours de
location des résidences principales
sur le l'organisme unique qui serait
désigné pour mettre en place la
plateforme de déclaration plusieurs
pistes sont encore à l'étude ce qui est
certain à ce stade c'est que le guichet
de centralisation ne sera pas géré par
une autorité administrative indépendante
ou par une autorité publique
indépendante car la désignation d'une
telle autorité ne pourrait se faire par
décret et nécessiterait l'intervention
du législateur la création d'une
personne morale Haddock n'est pas non
plus prévue faut pas multiplier les
personnes morales ou les organisations
étant donné la relative modricité des
moyens nécessaires à la gestion de ce
guichet et donc ce qui est envisagé à ce
stade et sans préjuguer de la décision
finale c'est l'attribution de cette
compétence a un service d'administration
centrale ou cette évolution un opérateur
de l'état existant
et puis interroger également sur
l'articulation avec le règlement
européen en cours de discussion
effectivement il s'agit d'une
anticipation partielle de la mise en
oeuvre du projet de règlement européen
proposé en novembre 2022 par la
Commission européenne sur la collecte et
le partage des données relatives au
service de location de logement de
courte durée
la proposition de règlement vise à
renforcer la transparence dans la
collecte et la transmission de ces
données et deux principaux objectifs de
ce règlement c'est l'harmonisation des
exigences nationales en matière
d'enregistrement et la facilitation de
la transmission des données entre
plateformes et autorité publique
compétente
à ce stade la proposition qui doit être
débattue au Parlement européen prévoit
que les États membres exigeants des
opérateurs numériques qui leur
communiquent des données mettent en
place un point d'entrée numérique unique
donc nous sommes parfaitement alignés
avec l'esprit du règlement à venir merci
Monsieur à mes collègues ont-ils des
questions complémentaires à bosser à
celle du rapporteur sur ce volet
particulier du texte
effectivement madame la Présidente
s'agissant les places de marché en ligne
effectivement il y a dans l'article 26
du projet de loi
une habilitation des agents CCRF à
rechercher constater les infractions au
disposition de l'article 25 du règlement
sur les services numériques qui proibe
les Dark patterns donc le Règlement sur
les services numériques c'est très des
réseaux sociaux et des places de marché
à cet effet les agents disposent de
pouvoir d'enquête prévu par le code de
la consommation qui sont considérés
comme des pouvoirs de police judiciaire
exercés sous l'autorité du procureur de
la République puisqu'il s'agit
d'infraction pénale punie à titre
principal d'un emprisonnement de
deux ans et d'une amende de 300000 euros
dans le montant peut être porté de
manière proportionnée aux avantages
tirées du délit à 6% du chiffre
d'affaires mondial
c'est donc l'ensemble des enquêteurs de
la DGCCRF qui pourront être amenés lors
de leur compte leur contrôle en ligne à
rechercher constater ses dark patterns
une enquête sur ce sujet sera ainsi
diligentée dans le cadre du Programme
national d'enquête de la DGCCRF pour
l'année 2024
voilà
bien merci monsieur le ministre dans mes
collègues
alors s'il n'y a pas de question
Monsieur Hervé rapporteur de l'autre
volet du texte on vous écoute attention
il y aura plein de questions aussi
de ne le faire qu'en une seule salle de
de questions ces questions étant plus
générale que que celle de Patrick était
plus technique sur le volet qui était le
sien première réflexion une très grande
partie des acteurs de l'Internet sont
établis en dehors de notre pays même et
beaucoup
d'entre eux sont en dehors de l'espace
européen
comment assurer l'effectivité des règles
notamment en matière de sanction pénale
que ce projet de loi propose de
soumettre à notre vote
j'en viens à la question de la
pornographie et à la question de la de
la régulation de l'accès des mineurs
dans quelle mesure la transformation de
la procédure judiciaire entre sur
administrative permettra d'être plus
efficace à vos yeux pour vérifier qu'un
contrôle de la majorité sérieux et bien
mise en place les sites semblent
déployer des moyens très importants pour
s'opposer au procédure judiciaire
j'imagine qu'elles feront de même dans
le cas d'une procédure administrative et
est-ce que l'arcome disposera de
suffisamment de moyens pour mettre en
oeuvre la nouvelle procédure qui
supposera l'établissement de constat par
ces agents
peut-être aussi vous pouvez vous
développer aussi les modalités
techniques qui sont envisagées sur la
question proprement dite du contrôle de
l'âge
c'est un sujet qui a été à de très
nombreuses reprises abordées dans cette
maison en particulier à la délégation au
droit des femmes et sur lequel on a
culture également et sur lequel on
s'interroge même si certains de nos
voisins européens semblent être
légèrement en avance sur nous je pense
notamment à l'Allemagne ou à l'Italie
le projet de loi répartit la compétence
de mise en oeuvre du RSN entre l'arcom
la CNIL la DGCCRF l'arcom est en
consacré en tant que coordinateur des
services numériques le choix de recours
à plusieurs acteurs procètent-ils d'une
spécialisation bienvenue au chrétiles le
risque d'une dispersion qui rendrait
dispositivement lisible et moins
efficace comment envisagez-vous une
coopération entre les différents acteurs
récemment la commission des lois a
adopter
une proposition de loi qui sera débattue
la semaine prochaine lundi
et dans cette provision loi un
amendement
permettait d'intégrer le président de
l'Autorité de régulation de la
communication du visuel et du numérique
ainsi que le président de l'Autorité de
régulation des communications
électroniques au sein du collège de la
CNIL
qu'en pensez-vous et réciproquement
est-il prévu qu'un membre de la CNIL
siège dans les différentes autorités que
je viens d'évoquer
les plateformes disposent-elles en
l'état des moyens techniques et humains
pour mettre en oeuvre les nouvelles
règles européennes ont-elles déjà adapté
leur moyen leur procédures à cette
nouvelle réglementation quel est l'état
du dialogue entre le gouvernement votre
ministère monsieur le ministre et les
acteurs du secteur s'agissant non
seulement de l'entrée d'application du
règlement mais aussi des mesures
autonomes prévues par le projet de loi
en matière d'interdiction d'accès aux
mineurs au site pornographique et de
renforcement la lutte contre les
contenus à caractère
pédocrinel
voire terroriste comment la France se
positionne-t-elle en ces matières par
rapport à nos voisins
et partenaires européens
comme le reconnaît implicitement l'étude
d'impact de votre projet de loi
l'application de règlement de couvrira
pas entièrement certaines dispositions
du droit national modifiées voire
abrogée par ce texte je pense aux
articles 29 et 30 qui vont passer le
seuil à partir duquel les plateformes
sont soumises à des obligations en
matière de transparence de lutte contre
la désinformation et on passerait de 5
millions d'utilisateurs nationaux à 45
millions d'utilisateurs européens et
c'est un choix délibéré de votre part de
ne pas prévoir de mesures
complémentaires pour les plateformes qui
ne se verraient dès lors plus soumises à
ces obligations disposez-vous de données
quant au nombre d'opérateurs n'entront
pas dans le champ des très grandes
plateformes et des très grands moteurs
de recherche au sens du règlement et qui
se verrait donc soustrait alors
obligations et ma dernière question
monsieur le ministre pensez-vous que la
loi du 21 juin 2004 pour la confiance
dans l'économie numérique gagnerait en
lisibilité en intelligibilité une fois
que ce texte sera adopté il me semble
que l'on continue à juxtaposer des
dispositifs sans une réécriture globale
je sais que c'est un sujet qui vous
préoccupe ce qui semble d'abord au
plonge juridique mais aussi au plan
intellectuel rendre les choses plus
complexes j'imagine que vous avez des
contacts nombreux avec un certain nombre
d'acteurs du secteur pour leur donner
des explications sur les évolutions
envisagées peut-être pouvez-vous nous
donner d'autres perspectives à l'issue
de cette discussion parlementaire merci
chez ministre merci Madame la présente
monsieur le rapporteur votre première
question
portée sur l'effectivité des règles que
le gouvernement entend soumettre à votre
votre puisque nous avons face à nous des
acteurs
qui se jouent parfois des frontières
j'aurais
répondre à cela avec deux éléments qui
me paraissent importants de rappeler le
premier de ces éléments c'est que
dans les les règlements européens que ce
projet de loi permet de faire appliquer
correctement dans notre pays comme dans
les autres États membres de l'Union
européenne
[Musique]
très important parce qu'on s'est souvent
heurté je pense au Luxembourg je pense à
l'Irlande à des appréciations par les
autorités en charge y compris de
l'application de règle européenne une
forme de déterrogénéité dans les
approches et puis deuxièmement
si certaines sanctions pénales
pourrait être peut-être plus facile plus
difficilement applicable à des acteurs
situés localisés très loin de l'Union
européenne les mesures de blocage en
particulier les mesures qui s'appliquent
au site diffusant des contenus
pornographiques aussi diffusant des
médias frappés par les interdictions
comme celle que l'Union européenne a
prises à l'encontre des médias russes
elles ne repose sur des acteurs français
les fournisseurs enfin des acteurs
français des acteurs basés en France les
fournisseurs d'accès Internet et dont
ils sont donc
je dirais d'effectivité immédiate et
rapide
s'agissant de l'accès des mineurs au
site pornographiques dans quelle mesure
la transformation de la procédure
judiciaire en procédure administrative
sera-t-elle un gage d'efficacité il est
bon à mon sens d'éclairer la Commission
sur la manière dont le la loi du 30
juillet 2020 a été appliquée à date
cette loi
cette loi précise que
l'interdiction qui est faite d'exposer
des mineurs
à des contenus pornographiques doit
s'appliquer aussi lorsque un site
internet par exemple ne fait que de
demander l'âge de l'utilisateur et ne le
vérifie pas sérieusement
le décret d'application de cette loi
était pris au mois d'octobre 2021
la loi et le décret d'application
prévoit ensemble que c'est l'arcom qui
met en demeure un site qui ne vérifie
pas l'âge de l'utilisateur
que lorsque au bout de 15 jours le site
ne s'est pas conformé alors l'arc comme
saisie le tribunal judiciaire de Paris
qui ensuite instruit l'affaire
en octobre 2021 le Tribune le LARCOM met
en demeure 5 des principaux sites
pornographiques de mettre en place un
système de vérification d'âge constant
qu'un jour plus tard que cette mise en
demeure n'a pas été suivie des faits
larcome au mois de novembre 2021 saisit
le tribunal judiciaire de Paris au mois
de septembre
2022 le tribunal judiciaire de Paris
convoque une audience qui rassemble les
sites concernés et l'arcane les sites
concernés se présentent à l'audience en
brandissant une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité le tribunal
judiciaire de Paris
renvoie la question prioritaire de vous
transmet la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité à la Cour de
cassation et ordonne une médiation entre
les sites pornographiques et et l'arcom
au mois de janvier 2023 la Cour de
cassation annonce ne pas transmettre la
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité aux conseils
constitutionnel et quelques semaines
plus tard
et quelques semaines plus tard le
annonce sortir de la médiation avec les
sites pornographiques le l'art comme se
tourne à nouveau vers le tribunal
judiciaire de Paris qui convoque une
audience qui s'est tenue au mois de
avril 2023 à l'issue de cette audience
le délibéré est attendu au 7 juillet il
aura donc fallu
un an et demi à peu près pour que le un
jugement puisse être éventuellement
rendu il nous semble important que nous
puissions aller plus vite et en confiant
à l'arcom la capacité après avoir
assermenté ces agents à cet effet de
const non seulement et de mettre en
demeure mais aussi d'ordonner plus
directement le blocage vous m'interrogez
ensuite sur
les moyens concrets que que l'arcom
pourra mobiliser pour exercer cette
compétence nouvelle
je veux d'abord rappeler qu'il faudra
qu'elle puisse disposer de moyens
humains pour cela
il y a aujourd'hui
[Musique]
370 agents à LARCOM en comptant les 16
antennes territoriales il y a
aujourd'hui
dit recrutement en cours pour la mise en
œuvre des des
responsabilités des compétences
nouvelles confiées à l'arcom par le DSA
vous m'interrogez également sur la
question de la vérification de l'âge qui
elle aussi avait fait l'objet de travaux
approfondi par la mission
parlementaire la médecine des sénatrices
et le rapport en fait état il est prévu
dans le texte que l'arcom a préavis de
la CNIL publie un référentiel qui dira
ce que doit être au minimum une solution
de vérification d'âge acceptable sans
attendre évidemment que ce projet de loi
ne soit adopté il appartient au site
internet concernait notamment par la
procédure en cours de mettre dès
aujourd'hui en place des systèmes de
vérification d'âge il n'en existe il en
existe certes ils ne sont pas absolument
parfaits mais il permettrait d'éviter
l'exposition massive des mineurs au
porno que que l'arcom a encore dénoncé
dans son dans son étude publiée il y a
il y a quelques semaines néanmoins pour
pour anticiper sur l'adoption de ce
projet de loi nous avons encouragé des
entreprises françaises à se saisir de
cette problématique la problématique la
vérification de la jeu en ligne en les
appelant à suivre les recommandations du
rapport des cénatrices celle de la CNIL
et de l'arcom et a essayé de développer
des solutions de vérification d'âge qui
soit doublement anonyme c'est-à-dire que
le fournisseur de la preuve d'identité
ne puisse pas de la puissance de la
preuve de majorité ne puisse pas
connaître ce pourquoi cette preuve est
utilisée peut-être sera-t-elle utilisée
pour consulter un site pornographique
peut-être sera-t-elle utilisée pour
l'achat de produits alcoolisés peut-être
sera-t-elle utilisée pour l'achat de
jeux de de
d'argent et de hasard qui sont eux aussi
soumis à des restrictions d'âge et puis
le site quant à lui qui va solliciter la
preuve de majorité pour donner l'accès à
son service à un utilisateur ne doit pas
avoir à connaître l'identité de la
personne concernée ée
vous m'interrogez ensuite sur la
répartition des compétences entre le
entre les différentes
autorités et la mise en oeuvre d'un
la mise en oeuvre du
RSN autour du coordinateur des
services numériques le RSN est avant
tout un règlement transversal qui
modélise un régime d'obligation appliqué
à un environnement de plateforme
intervenant sur une multitude de
secteurs économiques il est logique que
la mise en oeuvre du RSN soit organisée
de façon distribuée entre les
principales autorités de régulation qui
disposent en France des compétences
statutaires sur chaque domaine traité
par le RSN notre choix repose sur cette
double conviction privilégiez les
compétences et les expertises acquises
dans chaque domaine la CNIL pour la
protection des données personnelles
l'arcom sur les problématiques de
contenu la DGCCRF sur les pratiques du
commerce en ligne tout en veillant à une
coordination une synergie efficace de
l'ensemble nous sommes conscients des
écueils liés à cette gouvernance un peu
distribuer en différentes autorités
administratives et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le projet de loi prévoit des
dispositions particulières en matière de
dialogue et de consultation entre ces
différentes entités
vous soulevez ensuite une un point qui
était déjà soulevé dans le l'avis du
Conseil d'État sur le fait que le
règlement sur les services numériques
puissent écraser certaines des
dispositions de la loi contre la
manipulation de l'information que le
Sénat avait à l'époque passé au tamis de
de son examen et de son regard sur cette
question il est vrai que le le Règlement
sur les services numériques est un
règlement d'harmonisation maximale qui
interdit en principe le maintien au
niveau national de législation
poursuivant le même objectif notamment
en matière de lutte contre la
désinformation en ligne en conséquence
le projet de loi que vous avez sous les
yeux comme vous le soulignez abroche
certains dispositions de la loi relative
à la lutte contre la manipulation de
l'information qui prévoit certaines
mesures applicables aux opérateurs de
plateforme en ligne et en particulier
les articles 11 13 et 14 de la loi du 22
décembre 2018
néanmoins il est important de souligner
que ces dispositions abrogées sont
couvertes en grande partie par le
Règlement sur les services numériques
les articles 11 13 et 14 de la loi un
fox donc lutte contre la manipulation de
l'information ont des équivalents
directs dans le Règlement sur les
services numériques et les obligations
prévues restent donc pleinement
exécutoires ce règlement prévoit
notamment l'obligation pour les très
grandes plateformes et les très grands
moteurs de recherche d'analyser les
risques systémiques de désinformation
engendrées par le fonctionnement de leur
service algorithme système de
recommandation et de prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour les atténuer le projet
de loi n'entraîne donc pas de recul sur
ce point en outre s'agissant du code
électoral vous pouvez constater que le
gouvernement a suivi la vie du Conseil
d'État et n'a pas procédé à l'abrogation
de l'article
l163-1 mais à seulement procédé à de
légères modifications de cohérence avec
le DSA il a été décidé au regard de la
sensibilité de l'information des
personnes en période électorale de
conserver l'obligation pour les très
grandes plateformes et très grand moteur
de recherche de faire figurer les
informations listées par le présent
article cette obligation pourra ensuite
être abrogée avec l'entrée en
application du projet de règlement
relatif aussi blagage et à
l'amplification des publicités à
caractère politique un autre règlement
en cours de discussion au niveau
européen à l'étape des trilogues
l'impact de cette modification sera donc
quasi nul dans la mesure où les
dispositions agrogées ont un équivalent
dans le DSA et ou celle qui n'ont pas
d'équivalent dans le DSA seront
maintenus
janvier maintenant à la dernière
question
sur la question de la lisibilité de la
loi pour la confiance dans l'économie
numérique
il est
évident que
ce texte introduit des changements
importants à cette à cette LCEN qui sert
de socle à notre législation concernant
le numérique c'est une loi fondatrice
qui a porté depuis 20 ans un cadre
propice et dynamique en faveur de
l'économie de la société numérique près
20 ans de résultats compte tenu de la
transformation profonde liée à la
numérisation de l'économie à l'occasion
de l'adoption du RSN il est aujourd'hui
indispensable de refonder cette loi le
projet de loi s'emploie à cette
réorganisation à organiser réorganiser
le corpus de la LCEN pour le rendre plus
logique et lisible et l'articuler avec
ces règlements européens nouveau qui
vont continuer à vous arriver mesdames
et messieurs et sénatops puisque après
le Règlement sur les données sur la
gouvernance des données règlements sur
service numérique et marchés numériques
viendront le Règlement sur les données
le règlement sur intelligence
artificielle et d'autres encore
convocation à construire un marché
unique du numérique et appliquer faire
appliquer dans l'ensemble des États
membres un corpus de règles uniques qui
qui impose aux acteurs qui entendent
avoir des activités en Europe le respect
de principe auquel nous sommes très
attachés
ce qui nous oblige à une certaine
gymnastique il faut bien le dire dans
l'anticipation de l'application
transposition d'avoir au moins une
cohérence d'un texte à l'autre sur les
dispositifs qui sont retenus et proposez
bien sûr avant cela alors j'ai déjà des
questions forcément Annick billon à une
question je suppose que si la parole et
chers collègues manifestez-vous quand
vous avez des questions à poser merci
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
ministre d'avoir d'ores et déjà balayé
un certain nombre de sujets en réponse à
nos deux rapporteurs donc je fais
directement rentrer dans le sujet
puisqu'on a eu l'occasion de se voir et
de présenter nos conclusions de la
délégation aux droits des femmes porno
leur faire du décor donc juste quelques
questions pour essayer de laisser de la
place aussi au collègue qui auront des
questions à vous poser nous avions
préconisé la création d'une nouvelle
rubrique
sur la plateforme Pharos pour mieux
identifier on le voit il y a un problème
de visibilité d'informations de cette
plateforme donc de signalement donc
pensez-vous que la création d'une
nouvelle rubrique qui fera appel aux
actes de barbarie de violences sexuelles
notamment de torture serait de nature à
faciliter les signalements la deuxième
question vient par rapport
concernera aussi la dernière c'est sur
le droit l'oublier lors de nos travaux
avec la délégation au droit des femmes
nous avons évidemment entendu des
témoignages extrêmement violents
difficiles et
qui nous ont profondément impacté dans
notre regard sur l'industrie de la
pornographie et donc la question du
retrait des vidéos et de ce retrait
finalement serait-il possible selon vous
finalement
sans sans forcément le visionnage mais à
partir du moment où dans le titre d'une
vidéo porno vous avez l'apologie d'un
crime par exemple est-il pour vous
envisageable
de d'imaginer le retrait plus rapide
sans forcément se dire on vérifier dans
le contenu puisque ce sont des vidéos
pornographiques et qu'elles mettent en
scène forcément des actes particuliers
droit à l'oublier aussi par rapport à la
possible demande sans sans contrepartie
financière de la part des actrices
avez-vous des réponses assez à cette
demande puisque en gros une actrice de
porno gagne 400 euros pour une vidéo et
actuellement il lui est demandé entre 4
et 5000 euros pour le retrait de cette
vidéo donc quid du retrait quid du droit
à l'oubli merci pour vos réponses
monsieur le ministre
Florence platrix compta je prends
l'ensemble des questions monsieur le
mini si vous le voulez bien
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué l'inégale
diligence des différentes autorités de
régulation nationale à faire appliquer
les régulations numériques et indiquer
que dorénavant la Commission en aurait
l'achat
néanmoins on s'est posé lorsqu'on a
travaillé sur le DSA la question
suivante la Commission se donnera-t-elle
les moyens notamment les moyens humains
d'effectuer effectivement cette
régulation c'était ma première question
sur les moyens de la commission pour
effectuer la régulation et deuxième
question nous avons été lors de nos
auditions quand nous avons notamment
auditionné des acteurs qu'on essayant
très bien les réseaux sociaux nous
sommes rendus compte qu'il manquait
souvent de modérateurs et de modérateur
dans chaque langue notamment de
modérateur en français et c'est vraiment
une carence pour la lutte contre la
désinformation la haine en ligne donc en
quoi est-ce que ce texte va permettre de
répondre à cela je vous remercie je me
permets d'insister sur la question du
droit à l'oubli parce que ça a été aussi
des préconisations que nous avions
faites donc c'est vraiment un sujet qui
s'est retrouvé plusieurs fois évoqué au
Sénat
monsieur le ministre
merci Madame la présente mesdames
sénatrices sur la question de la alors
de la nouvelle rubrique mais en réalité
c'est alors je pense que c'était lié à
la question sur le retrait de certaines
vidéos
des sites pornographiques quand elles
sont
quand elles s'apparente à
des actes de
des actes criminels
nous avons à l'appui de vos travaux des
engagés des discussions avec
le conseil à l'égalité qui les a relayés
et
ma collègue Isabelle Rome pour
pour explorer les les moyens je dirais
juridique de caractériser de manière
suffisamment précise
une catégorie de vidéos
qui pourrait justifier d'être
retiré
cela nous devons vraiment le faire avec
à l'esprit de ne pas franchir
les lignes
de la liberté d'expression de liberté de
communication mais avec à l'esprit aussi
toutes les violences que vous citez
autrement dit le diable se nichant dans
les détails la question fond est de
savoir si de manière suffisamment
précise une
vidéo peut-être
identifier comme
comme un acte de barbarie et donc amener
à un retrait automatique comme cela est
prévu ou un pas automatique mais un
retrait sur sur un jonction de pharose
ou des forces de l'ordre comme c'est le
cas pour les contenus terroristes ou les
contenus pédopornographiques
mais j'ai de c'est un sujet auquel nous
dont nous avions parlé auquel nous
continuons de réfléchir sur lequel nous
n'avons pas encore trouvé la solution
et sur la question du droit à l'oubli le
rgpd le prévoit dans le cas des des
données ou des images qui sont des
images
personnelles qui n'ont pas fait l'objet
de d'un contrat
ce que vous proposez est devenu écraser
un contrat dans le cas que vous citez
qui est celui des images pornographiques
sur ce sujet le nous avons saisi le
garde des sceaux et le garde des sceaux
souhaite organiser un groupe de travail
réunissant les experts sur cette
question pour essayer de trouver une
réponse adaptée satisfaisante qui
mobilisera à la fois bon les le droit
des contrats en plus de celui du droit à
la vie privée à la protection des
personnes
sur les questions de Madame latrix
compta sur les moyens de la commission
c'est une question que que je pose à
chaque fois que je rencontre le
commissaire compétences c'est-à-dire
Thierry Breton nous avions il y a
8 mois des inquiétudes à ce sujet qui se
sont
dissipés puisque
les recrutements d'une de plusieurs
dizaines de réalité 80 et TP e-tp ont
été réalisés à la DG connectée à la DG
pompe pour l'exécution de ces règlements
mais tant que les je dirais tant que les
premières sanctions n'auront pas été
prononcées car il y aura nécessairement
des infractions
à ces deux règlements nous serons très
très vigilants à maintenir
ou à faire connaître à la Commission
européenne notre exigence très forte
qu'elle soit dotée de moyens j'ajoute
que
la beauté de ces règlements c'est que on
va solliciter de la part des réguler une
partie du financement de des moyens mis
à disposition de leur régulation c'est à
dire qu'ils vont contribuer
financièrement à cette à cette
régulation puis s'agissant de la
modération
les c'est le DSA qui désormais
va imposer aux plateformes de mettre en
place des disposés des dispositifs qui
devront être par ailleurs audité et qui
seront sanctionnés par des amendes
particulièrement lourdes
ce qui nous le pensons les conduira à
améliorer leur processus de modération
alors qu'ils ne passent pas toujours ou
pas intégralement par des moyens humains
qui passent aussi par de l'intelligence
artificielle notamment qui a sur
certains plateformes contribuaient à
éliminer beaucoup de contenus qui
étaient immédiatement
identifiables comme étant illicite en
tout cas beaucoup plus rapidement
qu'auparavant
et bien cette modération à la fois par
des algorithmes et par des moyens
humains et qui tiennent compte des de la
variété des langues des pays dans
lesquels ces services sont utilisés sera
désormais sanctionné par des amendes
particulièrement lourdes oui et au-delà
de l'audit de ces processus de de
modération et de signalement toutes les
plateformes devront c'est le cas en
France aujourd'hui puisque nous avons
pris un peu d'avance
publiés et faire la transparence sur les
retraits de contenu le nombre de
signalements qui auront été traités bref
les
informations sur leur activité de
modération
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors madame
Toine bourra
intervenir merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre moi je souhaiterais
aborder le chapitre sur le
cyber-harcèlement donc moi je suis
préoccupé par la proposition faite dans
la proposition de loi qui consiste à
bannir des réseaux sociaux les personnes
condamnées
pour avoir diffusé donc de la haine et
la violence sur les réseaux sur la sur
un réseau social et compte tenu du
décalage entre la vitesse à laquelle
fonctionne la justice et la viralité des
réseaux sociaux je me demandais s'il
était envisage envisageable en tout cas
d'imaginer des dispositions qui
enjoignent les réseaux sociaux à mieux
traiter à mieux réguler
les les signalements par exemple parce
qu'il me semble que entre le moment où
on est victime de cyber-harcèlement et
le moment où
l'agresseur potentiel sur le net et
condamné
j'ai bien peur que les délaiss soient
très très longs et donc que cette
disposition soit
inefficace
merci madame la Présidente vous avez
raison il y a assez peu de condamnations
aujourd'hui et
ces condamnations
en revanche mérite d'être
diffusé puisque on s'aperçoit quand on
regarde les ce qui étaient les
agresseurs de Mila qui étaient les
agresseurs d'édits de Pretto qui étaient
les agresseurs de Hoshi qu'on trouve là
des des personnes qui se pensant à
l'abri derrière un pseudonyme on
déclenché effectivement ou participer à
des raids de haine et de violence mais
sans soupçonner qu'il pouvait être
puni par des peines d'emprisonnement
car c'est c'est le cas
mais cette mesure de de bannissement qui
vient s'ajouter à une éventuelle
condamnation n'est qu'un des éléments
oui pardon alors je je voulais justement
donner quelques-uns de ces exemples
puisque nous sommes devant une
commission spéciale du Sénat et paraît
utile de rappeler les condamnations qui
ont été prononcées alors qu'on des
agresseurs des personnes que je viens de
citer
dans la dans la ferme il a c'est
12 mois de prison ferme qui ont été
prononcés à l'encontre d'un jardinier de
23 ans pour des menaces de viol et de
morts sur sur Internet puis en juillet
2021 4 à 6 mois de prison prononcés à
l'encontre de 11 personnes et 2 mois
plus tard 10 mois de prison pour une
personne ayant menacé Mila de mort dans
le cas d'Eddy de Pretto ce sont 11
cybers Arcelor qui ont été condamnés en
décembre 2022 à des peines de 3 à 6 mois
de prison
et puis vendredi dernier 8 mois de
prison dont deux mois de prison ferme
ont été
prononcés à l'encontre de l'un des
cyber-harceleurs de Hoshi et 5000 euros
de dommages et intérêts qu'il devra
verser à l'artiste 26 ans et cette
personne là en question a dit
qu'elle n'était pas du tout consciente
que ce que les actes qu'elle était en
train de perpétrer était sanction était
aussi grave et sanctionné par des des
peines aussi lourdes et donc il nous
paraît important que les peines
lorsqu'elles soient prononcées soient
particulièrement lourde et il nous
paraît que dans certains cas la
confiscation des réseaux sociaux la
confiscation pardon des ou en tout cas
la bannissement des réseaux sociaux
viendra ajouter à la au caractère très
symbolique de ces de ces de ces peines
qui qui doivent être connus pour que les
compartiments pour que chacun réalise
que il peut être poursuivi et que ce qui
est illégal dans la rue les de la même
manière sur sur internet mais ça n'est
qu'un des éléments du dispositif
réalité à 360 degrés que nous devons
mettre en place pour lutter contre le
cyber-harcèle et qui commence par la
sensibilisation des plus jeunes
notamment
et nous allons généraliser à la rentrée
prochaine le passeport numérique
c'est-à-dire la sensibilisation de tous
les élèves en 6e au risque et aux
attitudes à adopter lorsqu'ils sont
témoins ou victimes de cyber-harcèlement
et par ailleurs grâce à la loi du
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur grâce à votre
progression loi de programmation de la
justice en cours de discussion ici au
Sénat je souhaite que des des moyens
puissent venir renforcer les capacités
d'enquête et d'instruction de de ce type
d'affaires
j'ajoute que dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation et d'orientation initiale
intérieure on pourra désormais déposer
plainte en ligne et être accompagné par
un avocat lors du dépôt de plainte
autant d'éléments qui vont permettre de
d'accélérer sans doute ou d'améliorer la
prise en compte des plaintes des des
nombreuses victimes du cyber-harcèlement
faudra-t-il aller plus loin peut-être et
évidemment que nous nous étudierons
toutes les propositions d'amendement
qui seront les vôtres avec la plus
grande attention tant ce phénomène doit
être
contenue dans un premier temps puis
ensuite doit être éliminé
oui pardon j'ajoute enfin que le
règlement sur les services numériques
va imposer aux plateformes un niveau de
responsabilité particulièrement élevé et
une et par rapport aux droits existant
en France qui qui impose aux plateformes
lorsqu'elles ont connaissance de fête
cyber-harcèlement dit mettre fin à
condition qu'elles aient que c'est
faites cyber à seulement l'aurait été
signalé il y a deux choses nouvelles
dans le Règlement sur les services
numériques donc dès le 25 août
il y a deux choses nouvelles qui vont
qui vont intervenir la première c'est
que les plateformes devront aussi
signaler
donc la plateforme reçoit un signalement
elle va devoir traiter ce signalement et
mettre fin aux problèmes de
cyber-harcèlement mais elle devra
signaler ce phénomène aux autorités
compétentes ça c'est une première chose
et deuxième chose là où les peines
encourus en cas de non
respect de cette obligation aujourd'hui
dans le droit français c'est un an
d'emprisonnement et 250000 euros
d'amende on passe à 6% du chiffre
d'affaires mondial au maximum de
l'amende donc la responsabilité enfin la
peine encourue par la plateforme
augmente de manière très significative
merci Monsieur
ou remarques
moi j'ai une toute dernière question
parce que je note dans l'exposé des
motifs monsieur le ministre que vous
avez souligné
à juste titre que la présidence
française de l'Union européenne a été à
la pointe de cette grande avancée en
2022 il faut bien dire aussi que le
commissaire français Thierry Breton a
été très actif au niveau européen avec
les choses ont enfin bougé avec
plusieurs textes qui nous sont proposés
je lis aussi que le gouvernement en tant
que tunnel de porter de haute ambitions
dans ce domaine tant mieux le Sénat est
très attentif à cela de très longue date
vous le savez voilà la raison de ma
question du coup c'est que on a du mal à
comprendre quelle cohérence et quelle
lisibilité quand on voit il y a quelques
jours notre président de la République
déroulée en quelque sorte de tapis rouge
à Elon Musk le maire voilà qui ça donne
aussi le Fieg monsieur musk qui quelques
jours après finalement
nous défient en se retirant du code une
bonne pratique d'ailleurs il a été
rappelé à l'ordre sévèrement partir et
bretons en lisant le RSN s'appliquera
partout y compris à Twitter sinon
déférentra
Twitter donc on a du mal à comprendre à
la fois cette fascination pour ces
représentants des big tech et vous
l'avez dit vous-même vous avez dit que
les recettes publicitaires pour ces big
tech prime avant tout avant même la
sécurité des enfants vous l'avez dit en
prendre bulle à juste titre et on vous
soutient sur ce sujet donc on a du mal à
comprendre de même quand son temps
François le rendre Hollande avait
lui-même déroulé le tapis rouge à Margot
commun en pleine affaire cambrides donc
quelle cohérence quelle lisibilité je
pense que c'est essentiel pour nos
concitoyens de de bien comprendre le
sujet voilà pourquoi aussi le fait
d'avoir attribué la plateforme de notre
santé à Microsoft sans appel d'offre et
aussi une question qui nous a
particulièrement heurté voilà cette
fascination nous nous pose de questions
et donc on voudrait avoir des garanties
parce que on porte la même ambition que
vous et on se félicite encore une fois
que la présidence française était
proactive on va être regardé au niveau
international vous avez parlé des
Pays-Bas les rencontres que vous avez eu
je crois pouvoir dire que le rgpd est en
quelque sorte un étalon d'or on en parle
dans le monde entier dans les assemblées
par exemple parlementaires de la
Francophonie on est aussi attendu sur ce
texte donc voilà quelle cohérence quelle
lisibilité quelle ambition en définitive
voilà pleine et entière qui s'affichera
aussi en matière de politique
industrielle de soutien à nos
entreprises du cloud européen tout cela
est très très important pour nous
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente je crois que
vous avez tout à fait raison
et
quand on regarde ce qu'est ou ce que
fait Elon Musk bon tout récemment
c'est-à-dire il y a moins d'un an il a
repris un réseau social mais avant cela
il était il reste constructeur de fusée
et de voiture et de voiture électrique
en tant que tel étant donné sa sa place
sur ces marchés là bien sûr que comme
pour n'importe quel invv enfin n'importe
quelle si je puis dire comme pour les
investisseurs
étrangers
nous nous évoquons avec lui et ses
équipes toutes les possibilités
d'implantation en France de sites
industriels non seulement parce que nous
voulons revitaliser des territoires qui
ont subi de plein fouet la
désindustrialisation depuis des
décennies mais aussi parce que Monsieur
Mask
est ces usines
lorsqu'elles s'installeront en Europe de
fabrication de véhicules etc sera le
client des entreprises qui en France
vont concevoir des batteries électriques
donc nous avons la nécessité pour le
secteur automobile d'entretenir avec les
constructeurs les les meilleures
relations de manière à pouvoir jouer
dans les
l'évolution assez brutale du passage du
thermique à l'électrique notre partition
et de pouvoir garantir
une forme de de
en tout cas de réussite industrielle à
cette filière à laquelle nous sommes
attachés
et donc les projets de gigafactory que
nous avons réussi à tirer sur notre
territoire ben oui ils sont pas là
uniquement pour le plaisir de produire
ils ont besoin d'avoir des débouchés et
parmi ces débouchés il y a les
constructeurs automobiles dont
l'entreprise de Monsieur musk fait
partie ensuite monsieur musk qui l'a
repris l'année dernière un réseau social
qui effectivement ne relève pas autant
que la construction de fusées ou de
voitures de logique physique mais de
logique humaine et après un certain
nombre
d'expérimentations qui n'ont pas été
couronnés de succès
il
il a fait un peu la transparence
puisqu'il a ouvert son algorithme de
recommandation en open source mais il
semble rencontrer les de grandes
difficultés à se conformer à nos
attentes en matière de
lutte notamment contre la désinformation
le
l'annonce qui a été faite la semaine
dernière du retrait du de la signature
de Twitter du code volontaire de lutte
contre la désinformation n'est pas je
dirais une sortie définitive de ou en
tout cas une
une
un aveu de ce que Twitter ne se
conformera pas aux obligations puisque
ce code est volontaire et on peut
d'ailleurs très bien appliquer les
mesures du code de la désinformation de
bonne pratique de lutte contre la
désinformation tout en
ne signant pas on peut ne pas signer le
code tout en appliquant les pratiques
qui figurent dans ce code mais enfin
je suis pour ma part relativement
inquiet je ne vois pas de signaux très
encourageants sur la capacité de Twitter
à se conformer à cette partie là en tout
cas des obligations nouvelles qui lui
sont faites par la règlement sur les
services numériques malgré les
déclarations répétées qu'elon musk a pu
faire au président de la République aux
mises de l'économie et des finances et à
moi-même c'est-à-dire que de de
je dirais de
sa ferme intention de conformer Twitter
assez obligations et en particulier aux
obligations du DSA puisque Elon Musk ne
cesse de rappeler que le DSA est une
bonne régulation donc nous verrons le 25
août si Twitter c'est oui ou non
conformé et là deux deux choses l'une
soit il l'a fait et il aura le droit de
continuer à exercer sinon et bien la
Commission européenne sera fondée à
appliquer une amende lourde et je le
souhaite vivement qu'elle le fasse il en
va de la crédibilité de ses règlements
européens et donc de la réglementation
de la crédibilité de l'Europe
merci monsieur le ministre pour ses
propos rassurants
également sur ce sujet c'était
l'occasion de les de pouvoir les
exprimer comme nous n'avons plus de
questions je vais libérer mes collègues
et surtout vous libérer vous remerciant
beaucoup de nous avoir consacré ces deux
heures qui ont été utiles bien entendu
il y aura encore des échanges je pense
entre nous d'ici l'examen du texte
certaines propositions du Sénat vont
être une communion débat au sein de
notre commission pour pouvoir
parfaire par faire le le sujet nous
allons travailler bien sûr un rythme
soutenu d'ici début juillet juste avant
de nous quitter mes chers collègues je
voulais juste vous dire que nous nous
retrouvons le mardi 13 juin à 9h en
salle 245 et nous auditionnerons les
régulateurs hardcore Marcel CNIL
et l'après-midi à 15h30 en salle le 116
ça sera le pôle d'expertise de la
régulation numérique le jeune pérenn qui
fait un très bon travail d'ailleurs la
cohésion Tik Tok a eu l'occasion d'un
déplacement sur place et donc vous avez
déjà rencontré les responsables voilà
mes chers collègues
particulières je vous libère encore une
fois vous remercions les uns et les
autres pour votre disponibilité et je
note qu'il est 16h29 nous terminons donc
juste dans les temps à partir à cette
audition